scientists have been making rapid
progress in understanding RNA
interference or RNAi AI many organisms
use RNAi eye to control genes and it can
also be used as a tool in the laboratory
and in the future perhaps as a therapy
this animation will introduce you to the
principles of RNAi I involving two
important types of RNA molecule small
interfering RNAs and micro RNAs
eukaryotic cells have many sophisticated
ways of controlling gene expression in
the complex environment of a cell these
mechanisms need to be precisely targeted
there's a group of mechanisms that use
small RNA molecules to direct gene
silencing this is called RNAi I inside
the nucleus most genes that encode
proteins are transcribed by RNA
polymerase 2
the primary RNA transcript is processed
by splicing and forms a mature messenger
RNA sometimes called mRNA the messenger
RNA is then exported from the nucleus
into the cytoplasm here ribosomes
catalyze translation of the messenger
RNA to form polypeptide chains that fold
into proteins but this is also where
some small RNA molecules can have their
silencing effects there are several
types of regulatory small RNA small
interfering RNAs known as SI rnas are
derived from longer double-stranded RNAs
that are either produced in the cell
itself or are delivered into cells
experimentally the introduction of si
RNAs or double stranded RNA is widely
used to manipulate gene expression micro
RNAs are another type of small RNA most
micro RNAs come from RNAs that are
transcribed in the nucleus which then
fold and a processed before being
exported into the cytoplasm as double
stranded precursor micro RNAs
the double-stranded precursors of micro
rnas and si RNAs bind to Dicer
which is an endonuclease protein that
cuts the RNA into short segments most si
RNAs and micro rnas are approximately 21
nucleotides long the short
double-stranded RNA then binds an
Argonaut protein one strand of the RNA
is selected and remained bound to
Argonaut this is called the guide strand
the combination of the RNA and Argonaut
along with other proteins is called the
RNA induced silencing complex or risk Si
RNAs direct risk to bind to specific
messenger RNAs the targeting is precise
because it's determined by base pairing
between the si RNA and the target
messenger RNA si RNAs often have perfect
complementarity to their target sites
once bound Argonaut catalyzes cleavage
of the messenger RNA which will then be
degraded microRNAs also guide risk to
messenger RNAs usually only part of a
micro RNA known as the seed pairs with a
target messenger RNA this imprecise
matching allows micro rna's to target
hundreds of endogenous messenger rnas
targeting bio micro RNA can lead to
messenger RNAs being degraded or
translation being inhibited argonauts
and their small regulatory RNA cofactors
are found in plants animals fungi and
some bacteria and their importance in a
multitude of biological processes and as
tools continues to be revealed
you